ils étaient venus pour la dernière fois
sur notre plateau le 22 mars 2021 pierre
ménès venait s'exprimer sur des
accusations à son encontre des
accusations qu'il avait conduit à
quitter canal + depuis carmenes ses
tenues loin des médias pour tenter de se
reconstruire
vous avez passé sept mois on va dire une
traversée du désert on nous a pas vu du
tout médiatiquement ce n'est que
récemment qu'il est de retour sur les
écrans avec sa nouvelle plateforme
pierrot le foot un blog ou débat
d'opinion et analyses footballistiques
s'entremêlent à sa veine des interviews
on va essayer de parler d'autre chose
que de paris lyon et marseille et il a
décidé de recevoir eric zemmour comme
premier invité politique un choix risqué
pour un retour et qui divise merci
naître un monde première invitée
politique
le foot ce soir pierre ménès et sur
notre plateau son passage habite sa
lente reconstruction son avenir il va
tout nous dire ce soir dans tpm
ppr et des quêtes avec nos journalistes
sportifs merci pierre d'être là je vais
changer l'échelle jouer on appris à la
wii c'est ça ça fait des animations
maintenant
pierre merci d'être là huit mois tu es
plus à l'antenne alors et donc tu as
lancé sa plateforme pierrot le foot huit
mois après cette sortie de l'antenne
c'est aussi qu'après la décision siens
de sétois je sais qu'ils avaient dit
qu'ils avaient été tous ne sentais plus
haut si tu te sentais plus de faire
d'antenne en fin d'un commun accord
voilà c'est ça veut on était arrivé à un
tel déferlement de haine sur les réseaux
que
c'est les raisons qui ont fait que t'as
pas repris l'antenne ah oui
ouais bah oui complètement jouer à huit
mois plus tard je n'ai jamais eu dans la
rue une personne qui m'a insulté jamais
pas une enquête que les réseaux voilà
c'est bien reparti avec les mollahs
donc
c'est pas moi qui décide et je pense que
canal était tout à fait d'accord avec
cette décision mais où s est s était pas
confortable ni pour eux ni pour la
chaîne i pour toi c'est ça voila voila
moi j'ai jamais voulu faire
main nuire à canal qui a qui a été
exceptionnel avec moi pendant onze ans
et qui s'est même très très bien
comporté et là dans la fan notre
aventure donc je voulais pas mettre la
chaîne en difficulté non plus ça s'est
bien passé d'ailleurs son départ de
canal + je sais c'est
était triste quand même parce que denard
oui je suis toujours très fine ça tu
manques oui bien sûr mais je sais
traitement ouais bah oui
c'était ma ma vie pendant pendant 11 ans
cette émission
ce rituel d'arriver à
13h le dimanche je regardais les matchs
dans la loge avec ceux qui arrivent au
compte gouttes avec l'or qui arrive est
toujours le plus tôt enfin avait été la
plus tôt mais regardez pas les matches
avec nous y préparer l'émission oui ça
ça me manque mais là depuis trois
semaines je suis bien occupé ouais ça y
est et à un jeu sexuel mais tu t'en veux
tu en veux à d'autres personnes ou temps
il a aujourd'hui
plus de 10 kw à
linge ou écouté avec attention par les
d'harry comme bernard c'est un copain et
je suis très choquée
moi je signale juste que j'étais mis en
examen de rien en garde à vue de rien
donc il faut faire une
faut faire une balance moi ce sont
clairement les réseaux sociaux qui ont
eu raison et de mon travail à canal et
des contrats publicitaires que j'avais
appelé aucun contrat
ils avaient tous les noms mais je trouve
ça absolument terrible ça c'est vous
avez raison dans le cas des habitants il
ya eu mise en examen on verra bien après
on verra ce y est on y aura un procès
probablement une audience mais là on est
dans un cas chimiquement pur
c'est-à-dire de justice médiatique est
une espèce de lynchage de grande
injustice et contre lequel une fois que
la machine est lancée je pense qu'on est
complètement désarmé en fait je pense
que c'est très difficile mais moi je
dirais que oui il faut réagir oui il
faut porter plainte contre lesquels
l'ordinateur parce que ça mais là il
m'aurait fallu plusieurs batterie
d'avocats
il ya plein de gens ce soir que tu sûr
qu'ils vont en rien que vous dire vous
accueillez pierre comme une commune
victime
est alors que pour pour nous les
victimes ce sont ce sont les élus voilà
les jeunes filles qui voient là avec qui
il a eu des petits soucis mais c'est
vrai que toi aujourd'hui tu te
considères comme on
honnêtement j'ai c'est une plus y penser
j'y pense plus
l'émoi vraiment qui ont suivi ont été
très difficiles parce que je comprenais
pas ce qui m'arrivait et
je suis passé complètement à travers
l'euro qui est quand même à ma passion
en même temps est tellement de matchs
pourris que du mal à me concentrer et
puis le goût est revenue avec la
perspective de lancer ma place
voilà et c'est maintenant
je repars et des gens qui t'ont soutenu
anonymement plein plein et je leur fais
partie
cette vue hadj il en fait partie
mais
j'ai donc jamais demandé à personne de
me soutenir oui je vais le dire parce
qu'il aurait été pris dans la tourmente
moi je suis moi je suis de ceux qui se
disent quand un pote c'est une connerie
il faut lui dire mais il faut pas
laisser tomber voilà je sais pas moi je
suis dans ces trucs là et tu m'a souvent
dit moi aussi tu m'as dit des trucs sur
les émissions qui ne plaisait pas qu'on
te concernant pas du tout au goût des
trucs voilà cyril j'aime pas quand tu
traites ça quand tu t'es si ça ça nous a
pas empêchés j'aime pas ce que tu as
fais là je me serais tram voilà c'est
mais moi quand tu vois là dessus c'est
vrai je t'ai dit que t'avais déconner je
te le dis et comme estelle d'ailleurs
qu'il a dit qui est un pote estelle
denis et ça nous empêche pas après 2
voilà de d'essayer de discuter avec toi
et et de rester de rester pote avec toi
voilà je sais pas ce que vous entendez
une série que c'est ça c'est un gros
débat aussi ses amitiés et c'est vrai
que tu m'as tu as pu me dire plein de
fois moi j'ai eu un sms de toi et je
m'en suis jamais offusqué ouais cyril
sur ça je trouve pas ça bien tout ça et
tu peux me dire l'émission aujourd'hui
je trouvais pourri où tout comme ça
c'est pas pour ça que j'en veux à perdre
je la regarde moi mais non mais non mais
ça mais bon mais oui gilles moi je
trouve que c'est la franchise voilà de
dire tu as fait une connerie je te le
dis quand on est amis nous on se connaît
depuis très très longtemps on a
travaillé ensemble à l'équipe il ya des
dizaines d'années on a toujours été
franc même en cas de désaccord donc on
s'est parlé franchement c'était comment
as tu étais pas d'accord nous parler
franchement c'est à dire qu'on s'est dit
les choses on n'est pas d'accord sur ce
qui s'est passé mais je trouve que quand
tu as un ami quelqu'un avec qui on a
travaillé quand j'étais à l'équipe vous
m'avez vraiment sauver
professionnellement un moment je
n'oublie pas ça et je trouve que c'est
une forme de de gratitude et d'amitié
sincère que se dire les choses mais ne
pas lâcher les gens quand ils sont
abandonnés par beaucoup 1 et parfois
pierre a été très puissant très suivi il
s'est trouvé tout seul et se font que
c'est dans ces moments là qu'il faut se
manifester un petit message d'hier on
est là si tu as besoin voilà c'est
important plus fiable et vous rendez
compte que là ce que vous dites depuis
trois jours ont fait linverse avec
bernard montiel c'est à dire qu'hier on
lui a demandé de s'excuser nord à lens
en est ce que avec un si jeune âge je me
laissais de l'europe plaide au jury
ça n'a rien à voir non géraldine d'y
répondre parce que projetait la même
chose enfin saint pierre est arrivé non
chien ou pleines dents mais harry a
quand même une accusation de viol
mensing une présomption d'innocence
menace à la végétaline fait l'effet noël
les faits n'ont rien à voir excusez-moi
pu marquer si c'est de respecter et de
soutenir ses amis là me bernard depuis
deux jours il ne dit pas que l'histoire
une autre il dit simplement le réservé
la doua reproché hier et bernard l'a
très bien compris bernard sainz à ses
émissaires il a compris il a discuté
avec la jeudi c'est utile a dit je n'y
crois pas c'était parce que voilà il
voulait défendre son avis c'est tout
maintenant il a compris que je n'y crois
pas c'est on dit pas je n'y crois pas en
dieu je vais voir refuser un droit
virgile croire à tout le monde et lui la
loi dit
on le garde j'ai la même chose qui
assure dit à pierre bien sûr habitués
notre ami on sera toujours là pour toi
mais cette phrase là je n'y crois pas
les pas bien
ce qu'a dit ou pu faire bernard c'est un
pet de nonne ouais même par rapport à
mon histoire c'est un paint donne oui on
va demander à ses plaisirs de faire des
embrouilles
je comprends pas j'ai je le redis le
harcèlement qui continuent d'ailleurs tu
sais on me dit j'ai toutes les
l'association féministe qui me tombe
dessus alors que vraiment c'est moi
bientôt le violeur si je comprends bien
alors moi je parle de présomption
d'innocence de soutenir un copain j'ai
pas dis je ne croyais pas cette jeune
fille j'ai déjà dit cette présumée
victime j'ai déjà dis simplement que si
mon amitié a été trahi je suis obligé de
le répéter ce qui est quand même dingue
mais voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit et
là tout le monde me tombe dessus et ça
continue avec des insultes bien sûr tu
as dix ou si tu veux faire bah oui la
pierre d'assise et si on y croit ou on
n'y croit pas d'abord ça la justice de
trancher mal
justement il faut attendre que la
justice soit pour dire si ça dérange et
la fille de l'association la féministe
nous tt ça de dire ne pas croire tout ce
secteur en beauté les trois quarts est
formidable ouais mais on veut pas croire
les victimes mais continue de compte une
plainte est pas encore une victime les
appels je n'y crois pas ça veut dire
qu'on remet en cause la véracité choisi
un camp et on peut pas choisir un nom
qui m'intéresse à la juge nous arrange
pas choisir
vous vous demandez si bien venez c'est
une victime ou s'il est coupable pour
moi c'est une victime je suis désolé il
a fait une connerie il l'a reconnu il
s'est excusé n'y a pas eu en examen il
ya pas eu de condamnation en revanche
c'est une énorme condamnation médiatique
et professionnels il a tout perdu il
s'est fait défoncer sur les réseaux
sociaux et le problème c'est que ça
intéressait ça à exciter tout le monde
cette affaire pendant quelques semaines
les gens aujourd'hui 100 foot on n'y
prête plus attention mais la vie de
pierre ménès et le continu des sanctions
elles sont là au quotidien pour lui donc
clairement c'est une victime du tribunal
mais les solutions il n'y a pas de
regrets parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que vous
aurez pris la même décision que vous
avez pris aujourd'hui d'arrêter de
6 avait pas eu les réseaux sociaux
j'aurais pas perdu mes contrats
se rendent compte qu'elles le jeu lun
fameux jeu de foot dont je faisais la
voix depuis cinq ans ma virée sur
twitter
pierre ménès ne fera plus la voix du jeu
si vous voulez plus entendre la voix
pierre ménès vous pouvez mettre le jeu
dans une autre langue c'est ok et j'ai
reçu le courrier chez moi cinq jours
plus tard est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de la violence du truc avec le
procès médiatique à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui devenu même bien plus
important finalement car elles n'ont
même pas appelé pour me demander qu'est
ce qui s'est passé nu et a travaillé
dans à l'antenne surtout en voiture
dérobée médiatique me gêne mois quand on
parle des réseaux sociaux
faut arrêter de dire le parce que
facilement les choses qu'on ne rien
avoir en raison d'un
procès médiatique arriver là il faut des
gens et réseaux sociaux mais les réseaux
sociaux c'est moi car là c'est pas les
médias faut arrêter
de plus en plus sale manie de plus en
plus mathieu battu le cas de pierre et
d'historiens pas de mise en examen mais
lisabeth dans le cas d'arrêt habitants
on parle de la presse people c'est quoi
l'autre option la vraie vraie vraie
justice il quoi qu'il arrive c'est entre
4 et 10 ans c'est quoi le trop de gens
mais elle avec les il ya une véritable
gêne apparente
jamais autant arriver qu'à la victime
qui donne à l'état
entre trois et quatre ans la première
instance et si jamais si jamais mais
tout ça est un problème mais pour moi
willy un grand problème c'est qu'on
puisse détruire la ville d'auch il
s'assurait women femme paraît alors oui
ça va bien mais là il ya une véritable
question est est ce qu'il est possible
et la fille de john key à détricoter à
partir du moment ci avait pas les
réseaux sociaux réalité ou pourrait
décider groupe en attendant que la
justice passe jusqu'à la condamnation
doit sa réussite inhabituelle baisse
entre 5 et désolé tu en mets donc la
victime à l'alsace en 5 au 10 ans en
quoi ce à l'arrêt par la victime de voir
son nom soit disant son agresseur en
première page de magazine je crois que
ça je n'ai calmer le jeu dit qu'il
aimait la vie pas dérisoire des
engraisseurs son agresseur qui ait su
brésil mais s'il vous plaît soi-disant
serap la victime en résumé si pour
reprendre le terme de cyril la
plaignante oui je dois je suis navré on
peut pas rendre la vue six simplement je
vais dire pour répondre à l'émotion des
uns et des autres donc il faut des faits
divers tous les jours tu vas dans
le rôle d'un journaliste est d'informer
ses vous bien sûr la morale de machin
nous quand on relate les faits on dit
pas carrier habitants est
coupable mais là
excusez moi c'est juste factuel art
excuser de viola s'est il est accusé
vient pas de mise en scène bah non il
n'y a pas de mise en scène je suis
désolé gisèle elisabeth revenons aux
sources du métier le travail est fait
avoir l'info donc le secret de
l'instruction
mais l'info c'est quelqu'un qui a une
classe est mise en évidence son bien
alors agit donc on n est jamais là plein
de sa mairie s'est battu sur cette
action le cas sur le cas de pierre
qu'est ce que tu penses du quatrième
temps après tu l'a traitée tôt sur ton
journal boon ou très franchement vite
fait j'avoue on l'a pas parce que là
pour nous ç'a dépassé s'était pas c'est
pas comme dans le cas d'arrêt a du temps
où il ya une plainte il ya quelque chose
là c'est vraiment c'est pour le coup
c'est les réseaux sociaux qui se sont
acharnés sur lui et caetera et c'était
pas quelque chose c'était pas une info
voilà qu'on sortait ou etc c'est
vraiment un procès c'était à part ce
n'était pas dans le cadre d'une enquête
journalistique ou autres biens tu avais
dit aussi que tu étais venu sur le
plateau que tu avais subi le tribunal
aussi de l'émission vont nous est restée
voilà par la crèmerie tu me dis les
choses voilà mais c'est je peux
comprendre aussi que tu es mal vécu
l'émission qui avait fait chez nous tu
dis que tu l'avais regretté notamment
c'est géraldine il a même fallu c'est
que même voix la regarder j'ai du coup
j'ai regardé la séquence moi je suis a
priori pour les secondes chances la
résilience eu réduction votre avocat
était venu d'ailleurs un mois après je
crois bien connu et on a on avait
convenu que ça
voilà donc effectivement après will et
se sont acharnés mais il ya aussi
effectivement des femmes qui ont
souffert dans leur chair à l'exil reste
inapproprié tout ça donc ça mais pas non
plus le balayer d'un revers de manche
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que j'ai balayé
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas les caisses que
non mais moi qu'est-ce que j'ai balayé
tout mais moi qu'est-ce que j'ai balayé
à badens histoire j'ai rien valait rien
n'indique que j'ai rien j'ai rien éluder
donc j'ai juste eu le malheur de dire
que l'histoire de la jupe de marie je ne
m'en souvenais pas oui et non ça encore
une star moi je crois beaucoup au
traumatisme enfin vous avez bien
traumatisés parce que vous étiez
souffrant est très malade dont moi je
n'y crois absolument et pourquoi pas non
vous avez juste dit que à l'heure ni
tout on ne peut plus rien dire on ne
peut plus rien faire et maintenant a dit
roddick alors mythe où on dit non mais
qu'est-ce qui est ainsi que alors qu'est
ce qu'il a dit bernard peut plus rien
faire bernard on lui reproche une jarre
et où lyonnais entend s rien on chez de
mettre dans le même sac une mauvaise
blague ou une blague
pardon est-ce que c'est pas le problème
de mythes ou si vous voulez de nous à
bord
car en face de force vous avez peut-être
non je n'avais pas trouvé sympathique
mais mais ça n'est pas je ne vais pas
dire ce que j'ai été traumatisé mais
peut-être mais je suis tombé dans une
palpation corporelle dans les petites
choses parce que vous allez audio
journée seulement mais écoutez on ne
peut pas mettre dans le même banc
michelin n'est pas la même chose 2 ça
n'est pas l'avis finir la p17 tristane
banon merci pas de meilleur jeu mais
rappelez-vous la paire de la ligue du
lol oui rappelez vous il ya des gens qui
ont été virés de leur boulot alors que
personne n'était capable simplement de
sortir un message qu'ils avaient écrit
ils ont été virés dans une sorte de
rumeurs médiatiques et la chaire myriam
je vous la corde ce n'est absolument pas
la presse people c'est l'express
libération le monde il ya quatorze
personnes qui ont été décrits comme des
simples mais tu ne resterai pas ton pire
juste aujourd'hui donc t'as qu'à
plateforme pierrot le foot tu penses que
tu vas revenir on télé ou pas tu as
envie oui oui j'ai envie mais là je suis
très très concentré sur la plateforme
c'est une grosse pression d'accord moi
qui ai jamais vraiment tellement la
pression professionnelle manqué toujours
vécu les choses il ya des gens qui ont
dit qu'ils avaient reçu eric zemmour
pour la première qui t'ont qui sont
tombés dessus alors ce n'était pas la
première c'est la première personnalité
politique
oui alors l'appareil déferlement de
haine je suis un nazi je suis
donc c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire quand je vais recevoir mélenchon
mois idéal gauche de lance des messages
quand tu pourras jean luc mélenchon et
nigel gault si vous voulez tu vas
recevoir anne hidalgo ils vont dire que
tu es dans le btp
ouais je fais venir avec mes plans mais
et ça ne prend pas
ce qu'on a fait ces reproches l'aarc
es-salaam et lorsqu'ils ont refusé moore
non moi j'ai même pas le droit
et pourquoi pourquoi zemmour en premier
parce que c'est le premier qui m'a dit
oui à séparer son téléphone je les
appelais ou effet rien une interview sur
le foot il a dit oui je vais proposer
endroit et on pourrait faire ça ou 3 aux
bulls et plus ces meutres les trois opus
pour la porte de saint-cloud s'ajouter
du parquet ni c'est plus ça c'est ça
s'est très bien passé on s'est accroché
en face je lui dis que j'étais pas
d'accord notamment que lorsqu'il a parlé
de benzema mais d'où j'ai pas le droit
d'interviewer et mots mais les gens sont
en bray les gens sont en bray et
j'ai la corde de valérie pécresse on
fera ça débute et début 70 j'ai fait une
demande officielle au président macro et
je vais essayer de faire tout le monde
4-1